The red states on this map still have 7 25 dollars as minimum wage.
Do you wanna know how much 7 25 is every year?
It's 15 thousand dollars. Which means
the fast food workers in all of the red states
are at a 50 thousand dollar annual disadvantage
because the average cost to live in America
is about 77 thousand dollars.
Before you tell me oh,
all the fast food workers are just teenagers that want extra money,
that's false because about 30% of fast food workers are teenagers,
meaning about 70% of the fast food workers are not teenagers.
As a matter of fact, 40% of fast food workers are either 25 or older.
2024 alone, chick fil A brought in a 47 million dollar profit
and McDonald's brought in 1.6 million dollars of profit.
Quick service restaurants,
otherwise known as fast food,
brought in over 40 $490 billion of profit just in one year.
7 25 is still acceptable in some states as minimum wage.
But then if you're homeless,
you get criminalized because that's not okay
according to Scottish. This is why unionizing and support
and supporting measures that support union workers
are so freaking important.
Is an absolute abomination
that 7 25 minimum wage is still build a thing in 2024.
As a country, we're way better than this
and we need to move on.
And we need to choose accordingly on our ballots
so we can continue to help and support union workers
and people who want To unionize